on va discuter avec elles qui m'ont
varappe était une star de télé réalité
tu as fait qu'elle de télé les
marseillais les maranges les princes de
l'amour non ces minutes pour trouver ces
parties toutes les questions concernant
l'animateur tv maintient aussi
aujourd'hui il ay larrouy mais c'est un
très gros oui pour moi star ces acteurs
est ce que vous êtes un acteur
oui vous avez un lien de parenté avec
quelqu'un sur le plateau pour paris ils
attendent de gains alors moi je veux
dire comme les autres est rudoyé king
l'eau vous avez 30 secondes pour trouver
qui si vous avez toutes les questions
possibles par rapport à la démarche
jean pierre castaldi
[Applaudissements]
le scandale at il été inventée de toutes
pièces non non on va avoir la réponse
magali barras vous connaissez toute la
sphère magali car l'amour où elle est
dans votre agence oui d'accord va julien
malland donc ils sont origine
alors moi je pense que kevin donc qui
est le compagnon de carla il est parti à
dubaï
il s'est déplacé parce qu'il s'est dit
pas de notes vocales pas de textos rien
écrit il n'y a aucune trace
je vais aller mettre un petit coup de
pression parce que j'ai peut-être des
bye j'ai peut-être des doses contre vous
aussi donc maintenant vous allez vous
taire sur ma femme vous allez arrêter de
faire des histoires pas possible sur les
réseaux sociaux
et ça a fonctionné puisque maeva amis
justement ce message en s'excusant carla
effectivement est allé voir une voyante
dès l'âge de 17 ans ça fait 17 ans
qu'elle consultait cette personne et lui
a donné un million trois cent mille
euros
elle ya donné pratiquement un million
deux cent mille euros en quatre ans à
dire donc à lui donne l eau des 300000
euros par an à cet arrêt et après ça a
dégénéré effectivement en chantage
extorsions de fonds et cetera mais
effectivement carla était consciente
qu'elle allait voir une voyante
effectivement il ya eu des tonnes de
tubes par an oui il ya eu des notes
audio qui ont été faites car là ne renie
pas ses notes audio l'avouer donc ya pas
de montage vous avez voulu analyser les
images très vite pourquoi parce que vous
êtes dit je veux savoir la vérité
mais c'est exactement ça c'est à dire
que vous aussi vous avez tous vérité
vous avez défendu heuzé claire mét et
roule exactement on a été touché par le
témoignage que je veux bien comprendre
que c'est l'empathie parce que moi aussi
j'ai été touché comme vous et moi aussi
quand j'ai vu les premières images
mais ensuite quelque chose est dit que
vous avez lé président ils ont déconné
mais non c'est pire que déconner c'est à
dire que quand on voit les cinq secondes
on s'est dit tout de suite mais ils ont
rien à faire dans la coulisse et jean la
tête mais en plus on nous parle de
propos racistes
si rien à faire ma peau lissée sur le
premier rapport au premier abord et les
images démontrent clairement que il est
l'inventeur voilà et il y avait une
vingtaine de policiers autour qui n'ont
absolument pas vers écoute et voilà
c'est bien d'ailleurs lancé ma deuxième
émission parce qu'on fait justement la
deuxième émission sur la deuxième vidéo
et il a perdu un soldat en 7 6 0 il a
perdu l'usagé de son bras est il à 180
jours d'itt et et quand on sait que la
mesure légale c'est-à-dire que le seuil
légal qui permet de caractériser un
délit ou un autre est fixé à 8 jours
d'itt et et là on est à 180 jours d'itt
et et sert plus de 20 fois
justement le
le on va dire le seuil qui est imposé
par le code de procédure pénale on se
dit que c'est pas rien c'est à dire on
pas là on parle comme si c'était quelque
chose d'irrationnel
vous pouvez avoir un avis face à un
autre on a quand même un type là qui est
qui qui en situation de handicap à la
suite de cette intervention alors qu'ils
ont été incarcérés mais je pense qu'en
france aujourd'hui on incarcère pas les
gens comme ça à plein ses activités dans
toute cette affaire qui sont peints qui
sont pas là il juge a décidé de les
mettre en prison est aujourd'hui sont
sous contrôle judiciaire donc on n'est
pas dans une posture qui est neutre
vous êtes ancien fonctionnaire moyen
aura des comme vous on se portera je
vous lis des chinois huawei
c'est bien il faut vous faut devenir
ministre de l'intérieur drôle s'il avait
passé en les bars on a su être patient
j'ai juste bordeaux par patient s'il
pense qu'elle doit donc voilà je suis
policier ma carte est ici voilà pourquoi
suspendu six mois pour information oui
oui vous vous êtes d'extrême droite donc
voilà donc si vous voulez on colle les
étiquettes seafrance police c'est un
syndicat d'extrême droite comme ça on
s'est loupé
incroyable non mais voilà l'incroyable
disais que tu comment que que ce que ses
deux parents ont été des racistes oui
mais vous voulez vous dites on n'a
jamais dit c'est bien si mais si ça ah
oui la vidéo oui oui oui alors je vais
vous dire il ya un moment mais non non
non je me dis ça mais attendez attendez
jamais dit ça mais toutes vos émissions
que je peux vous dire ce qu'ils étaient
au fond là bas oui mais ce que je lui
dis moi non mais attendez exactement ce
qui s'est passé c'est qu'ils avaient
écrit sale [ __ ] en gros ici d'accord
encore une fois si mes collègues avait
ne serait-ce que une once de racisme je
défendrai jamais qui s'appelle ludovic
chancel vous
mario non mais vous dites n'importe quoi
mais vous dites n'importe quoi vous êtes
une mythomane caractérisé n'avait jamais
été marié avec des villes françaises
donnez moi on est en direct
on aimerait vraiment que ça se passe
bien avec terry n'ya pour l'heure exacte
mois que je me suis emporté dans votre
émission et que ce n'est pas ma façon
d'être
ni mon éducation de merci monsieur assi
yoplait mais j'étais très proche de mon
père est de savoir qu'une personne comme
elle qu'elle se dénigrer ma famille et
tout particulièrement mon père qui est
décédé en 2013
en utilisant les réseaux sociaux m'a été
insupportable
lorena aimerait que tu désactive le
comte tik tok tu as créé à son nom alors
nos lois nos médias vous répondre à
pierre il ya eu tort
c'est en rapport à toi où est ton ami
fred commun on n'aime là je n'ai jamais
traité dans la boue comme vous faites
dans les priorités attentats je ne vais
jamais dans la vraie vie
j'avais 13 ans et jamais traité dans la
boue comme toi tu fais avec fred qu un
jour il y en a un qui a très bien parlé
aux haïtiens sur le plateau yun
appellerait sortaient tous les régimes
des relais il a tout compris à l'essai
au blé et sortez tous les deux un métier
où je sortais tout